life as a prophet, as a
messenger, is historically
categorized and into two eras.
The first era is the Meccin era
before he made his migration to
Medina. And the second is the
Madani period when he made his
migration after he made his
migration to. Medina Maki
and Madani. While it is a
reference to the place, it is
actually a name of an era. It's
not the name of the place in
this context. So, when we say
this is a Meccan chapter, it
could have been revealed
elsewhere. What's important is
that, it happened in the era of
Mecca, meaning prior to Hijra.
And post Hijra is even if it
was revealed in Mecca. is
a chapter according to all the
scholars of Islam. However, it
was revealed in was revealed in
Mecca because it was after
Hijra, therefore, it is
categorized as Madini. We know
that this chapter is one of the
later chapters to be revealed.
Some of the scholars such as
in his book Tafir Al Quran Al
Kareem. what's known as
mentions that this chapter was
revealed after Surat Ibrahim.
Surat to Ibrahim is a later
Surah and you can really tell.
How can you tell? If you know
the prophet
history well. If you know his
biography well, you'll know
that first he was appointed as
a prophet in Ramadan.
and that this occurred 13 years
before his migration In the
cave of Hera. This narration is
well known. most of us have
heard the story. And so when he
was appointed as a prophet and
those first verses were were
revealed to him
He was appointed as a prophet
but he was not yet commanded to
to invite and to call everyone
to Islam. It was a phenomenon
that happened to him and he was
it was to his discretion. He
didn't have to tell anybody
about it. He didn't have any
particular message per se to
call people to as of yet. And
so the scholars mentioned that
he was appointed as a prophet
with Iqra. And he was appointed
as a messenger with deather.
Because death was revealed
right after Surat Iqra. Now, in
Allah clearsly clearly tells
him
you know call to Islam. and
When
he began to call to Islam,
it wasn't a it wasn't a
collective call. It wasn't a
call to everyone.
Mentions a number of stages
that the Dawah went through.
That is calling of people went
to went through and the stage
is that his spreading of Islam
went through. First of all, it
was to himself. Second of all
the second phase was his close
family members, right? Third of
all, it was his close tribesmen
and the people of Mecca and
then after that, it was anybody
else that came to Mecca or
outside of Mecca. These were
the four stages that the
prophet went through in his
Dawah and so, we see from this
that things were kind of
warming up throughout his
Mekken era. First, it was just
him and his very close
relatives just
Khadijah just very close.
Right? Then after that it
expanded a little more. And the
Dawah became more general and
his close tribesmen. And this
is when this is the era when
the prophet
stood on the mountain and
called everyone. And they and
he said, if I told you there
was an army coming from the
other side of this mountain,
would you believe me? This
story happened in that phase.
This was a little while. This
was a few years after. Now, why
was it that? Because
obviously, not everybody is not
people aren't going to be told
when he told Abu Bakr told Omar
or told Alib and Abu Talib and
Khadijan. It wasn't this
needs to be kept a secret. No,
it's Wasn't a secret thing. It
was just he told those who were
close to him And it was to
their discretion. And so words
started to kind of spread
amongst people. Even though he
had not specifically said it.
And this was kind of to ready
people's minds for what was to
come. So, we know that if we
know these stages of the Dawah
we know that we can read a
chapter from the Quran and we
can tell what which era it is
from. Is it from the Meccan
period or is it from the
period? We can tell because the
people that Allah is speaking
to, the one the people Allah is
speaking about, the type of
people, the type of responses
to certain arguments. There are
argu which are purely mechan
arguments, alright? Such as the
rejection of resurrection. This
is something that was kind of
unique to the pagan Mechans at
the time. likewise, when we
find chapters speaking about
Christianity, that is something
that came after Hijra because
there weren't any Christians or
Jews in Mecca and if there are
any responses to the people of
the book, in Mecca, it is very
scarce and it's because the
people of the had somehow
communicated this to the
prophet otherwise most of those
issues are dealt with in
Madinah. Also, you'll find that
the length of the verses
actually are they change. The
length of the verses and the
Meccan period are very short.
They're very taught and they
kind of rhyme and they're kind
of almost the same amount of
syllables whereas in the
period, the verses get longer
and more elaborate. They're not
speaking about general things
that verses are speaking about
very detail issues with regards
to law and governance and so
forth and the verses become
longer. Also, is something that
is mostly specific to the
Madini era. and the Meccan
period was usually right? But
this is not an absolute law.
This is not an absolute rule.
There are exceptions to each
rule. We also noticed that
there is a change in the tone
in the Meccin period because
the climate was changing,
right? At the beginning, it's
just giving the facts.
Right? So, it's just commands
and general but when the people
of Mecca are invited to Islam
and they reject Islam then it
starts speaking about mockery.
they were kind of mocking
the prophet and then it comes
to them harming the prophet and
his followers. Right? Physical
harm. financial harm. And
these chapters they're very
clear because Allah's speaking
about those incidents that
happen with previous prophets.
Like
here. So, is going to be
roughly placed at eight or nine
9th year after prophethood
about four or five years before
Hijrah. Somewhere around there.
We can't be absolutely sure.
There's no way to be absolutely
positive if we don't have a
clear cut statement from the
prophet or his companions. But
we can kind of put it there
roughly. Right? Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala opens this chapter by
saying
that people
people's reckoning is coming
swiftly close Yet, they are in
a state of spiritual
needlessness. And kind of a
spiritual fog. That they are
in. So, there reckoning is
swiftly approaching. Yet are in
they are in a state of
heedlessness and they are in a
state of spiritual slumber.
Now, what is meant by their
reckoning? The people's
reckoning. Anytime you read
this verse, it's never been
more true for you than than the
time you read it. Why? Because
every single day, we are closer
than we've ever been to death
ever. So, today, Right now,
everyone of us, you and I, we
all are, have never been closer
to our death than we are right
now, right? And so, this verse
rings true every time we read
it and it is even more and more
true for us every time that we
read it because every time that
we read it, we are closer to
our death than we've ever been
before. And this in itself is
not necessarily bad. what makes
it bad? It makes it bad if you
are in a state of heedlessness
and spiritual slumber. In this
case, it's bad. It's not a good
thing because the clock is
burning and we are kind of you
know, just we're we're we're
not really taking things
seriously, right? Of course,
this verse was revealed
regarding the disbelievers of
Mecca. They of personify the
full extent of heedlessness,
the full extent of spiritual
slumber. However, it also
applies to everyone of us in
some way. Because none of us is
completely free of
heedlessness. None of us is
completely free from spiritual
slumber. Raffler. We're just
not.
was famously quoted as saying
he said, people are asleep and
when they die, they will truly
wake up. That's when they wake
up from their sleep. And so,
this is what makes our swiftly
approaching reckoning, that's
what makes it scary. That's
what makes it terrible and
that's what makes it tragic. Is
that we are in this state and
our death and our reckoning is
swiftly behind us.
Hadiel Jumla.
[Silence]
Listen to it while in a state
of play and idol. in a state of
play and idle and just, what
does this mean? This means that
they listen to the prophet
there's a difference between
hearing and listening, right?
In Arabic, there is and in
English, there is. We hear a
lot of things but we don't
listen to everything. Here
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that they listen to the
prophet listening is a
voluntary you voluntarily do
that. It's swallowing
something. That's a voluntary
act. If something ends up in
your stomach, you voluntarily
swallowed it. Likewise, if you
listen to something, you
voluntarily are taking this
into your, into your hearing
and into your ears. Likewise,
if you observe something is
different than seeing it. We
see a lot of things, things
that we don't want to see. We
hear a lot of things, things
that we don't want to hear. But
we only listen to things that
we want to hear. And we only
observe things that we want to
observe. That we want to see.
And so these people are
listening to the prophet
they're listening to the Quran.
The new verses of the Quran
that are revealed. They are
listening attentively. But
they're not believing. Why?
This goes to a root issue which
is the issue of determining,
rejection, before hearing the
evidence. So, they have
determined no matter what I
hear, tonight, or today, no
matter what it is, I'm not
going to believe but it sounds
good. So, I'm going to be
entertained by it. It's
entertaining. You know, sounds
good, it's great, it tells
great stories, there's a lot of
wisdom in it but I'm not
going to ever believe. I refuse
to believe. So, they refuse to
believe before they've even
heard the message Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
They disbelieved in it and they
haven't it has the message
hasn't even been fully
explained to them yet. How can
you how can you make a
judgement on something
especially as as grand and as
immense as a judgment of what
is going on in the hereafter?
Is this person a prophet or
not? without any evidence.
Of course, for us instance,
does this mean that everybody
who speaks, we need to listen
to them first before we we we
come to a conclusion? No. If a
person comes in today and says,
I'm a prophet, listen to my
message. Do we listen to him?
No, we determine primitively
that he's lying, correct? But
we do that with evidence.
Because the Quran tells us that
because the tells us that. We
do that with evidence. These
people have no evidence. What
is dictating their rejection
and distinguishing it from
their acceptance is their
desires, their whims, what they
what they don't like. I
don't the idea of being
resurrected so it doesn't
exist. That kind of attitude. I
don't the idea of this man
being a prophet and not me. And
there are people that reject
the prophet's message because
of that. or he should have been
from our tribe, not from Benny
Hashem and so, no matter what
he does or says, we reject it.
There's no evidence. It's not
evidence they're using. It's
not facts they're using. It is.
It is pure desire. Or pure fear
of something that they have
that they want to continue
having or some fear of not
having something or or of
having something that they
don't want to have. Etcetera.
And so these are the many
reasons why people reject the
message of Islam. People do not
reject the message of Islam
because it makes no sense.
Because it's illogical. Because
some other book tells them that
this is impossible. There's
nothing that. There is
nothing this at all. There
is nobody, noone that can
listen to the message of Islam.
And then come to a sound
conclusion that this makes no
sense. We could come to that
conclusion regarding the
trinity. Yes, you know, three
is one and one is three and all
this kind of, yes, that's, we
can't believe that. However,
one plus one equals two. There
is no other answer. This is
called deduction. the premise
is correct, then the conclusion
is correct. There's no way to
reject a deductive argument.
It's impossible. It's
illogical. and so,
with
deductive reasoning, noone
can soundly ignore the message
of Islam. Usually, what makes
people reject Islam is what? Is
are the implications of Islam?
Oh, this is going to change my
life. Oh, I'm going to have to
dress different. I'm going to
have to eat different. I'm
going to have to speak
different. I can't do this
anymore. People I aren't
going to me anymore.
People I don't I have to
like. Things that. That's
what causes people to reject
Islam. Not that come to an
honest, objective, deductive
conclusion that this cannot be
correct and this is why the
hellfire exists. This is why it
exists. It's not because
anybody was confused.
Rasulullah. That's the
condition for a person to be
punished. You cannot be
punished. You will not be
punished by Allah until a
messenger has come to you.
Whether that be in person or by
transmission. That messenger
has come to you, that means
that you understood the
message.
And so, if you've understood
that message and rejected it,
even if you come up with a
whole bunch of things later,
everybody comes up with things
later. Right? Just when
people say something and then
you ask them about it, they
say, no, I didn't mean that.
No, that's not what I meant.
Anybody could say, that's not
what I meant later. We by what
you say at first. Usually, what
people say first is what they
meant. Likewise, they will
reject first and then they will
come up with all kinds of
reasons why this can't be
correct. That's irrelevant.
That doesn't change the price
of tea in China as we say. That
doesn't matter. Whatever people
come up with later doesn't
matter. Iblis rejected the
truth. What is the truth that
he rejected?
is rejection of truth didn't
come in the form of I don't
believe that Allah told me to
prostrate to Adam. He didn't
say that, right? I mean, what
what clearer truth is there to
reject that when Allah is
speaking to you directly and
you say no. That's about as bad
as it's going to get, right?
but he, in spite of that, in
spite of the angels, all know
he's on nonsense and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala clearly
knows what he's going to say
before he says it, that it's
rooted in arrogance and and and
jealousy. In spite of all that,
everyone knows, Adam, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, Adam, the
angels, he, everyone knows.
That he just doesn't want to do
it. But in spite of all that,
he still comes up with some
argument.
He still says, well, I'm better
than him because of this and
this and that. He knows that's
nonsense and everyone else
watching this incident knows
that that's nonsense but people
don't usually just reject the
truth and say, yes, I
acknowledge this is the truth
but I rejected. Some people do
but very rarely. Most of the
time, people kind of build this
kind of dust storm around
themselves to hide their
intentions. That's how people
usually act. Hello.
[Arabic recitation]